a few weeks ago uh there was a story
that got some attention in the media
about a pet psychic that had apparently
communicated with joe biden's
dog um the media had time to report on
this story because obviously there's
nothing else important happening in the
news right now
now as far as i know joe biden did not
bring his dog
to the pet psychic for a reading which
means either that the dog went himself
to consult the psychic or
the psychic read the dog's mind from a
distance across time and space and
without the consent
of either the dog or the dog's owner and
this is why i have long said
that non-consensual mind reading of
humans or animals
must be banned but leaving aside
legislative issues like that
this all really piqued my my curiosity
what exactly is involved in reading a
pet's mind
what do pet psychics do besides take
money from credulous idiots
now i don't mean to come on too strong
here i i admit i'm a bit of a
skeptic um in fact the the existence of
pet psychics the fact that that even is
a business
a profitable business presents me for me
the strongest temptation to socialism
that i've probably ever felt
i mean i respect the free market but
this is just too far
the free market is drunk it needs to go
home and sleep it off i think
it's just it's too much but then again
maybe i'm being too cynical
maybe there's something to this pet
psychic thing
and that's why we're gonna watch a
couple of videos and see if maybe
there's
something really supernatural happening
here there could be i don't know
so first this is a video from uh
buzzfeed their staffers
have taken a break i guess from writing
lists of the top 10 blocks of cheese
that look like george clooney
and have decided to sit down with a pet
psychic instead
maybe a better use of their time i don't
know but let's uh let's check it out
he's a big fatty and hi leo
leo he said tell her not to say that
told he actually he said tell her not to
call me that
that's called leo no fatty
you know i had a dog when i was a kid
and i looked at the dog and it's like a
dog you know the dog's an animal
and uh and never thought of treating the
dog
as an an equal in a way let me get out
of
here
he has a communication to you i hear an
animal
the way i hear anybody i'm having a
conversation with
when they say something they're saying
it and they're
saying it with specific words and
specific attitudes
okay let's just stop there for a minute
dr doolittle here says that she hears
animals the way she hears a person that
she's having a conversation with
in other words she hears voices in her
head there's a name for this it's not
being a pet sidekick it's called
schizophrenia and there's a treatment
for this disorder that's the good news
all right let's go back to it could you
please tell my owner that i am not going
to die
so i don't know if you have oh my god
that's so weird
oh my god that's so weird how did she
know that how did she know that the
pet's owner doesn't want the pet to die
how could she possibly have known that
the only explanation literally the only
explanation is that she is a magical
witch
who can use the power of her mystical
mind waves to have coherent
conversations
with animals that's the only way that
that could have possibly happened
um of course the other possibility is
that all pet owners feel that way
you know so it's sort of a lucky guess
well most do
um i have a cat you know it's my wife's
cat and i can't say that i'd be
terribly broken up if the thing finally
went off to the great
litter box in the sky um but i'm a
unique case
probably one of the things that i do
with animals
i call emotional clearing and it's
basically moving energy
so i transmute energy blocks
that i can feel in an animal
whether it's in an animal's body or
mostly in their emotions
and in moving the energy that was stuck
a lot of times they have a realization
that
uh comes with the release that they have
and they lighten up okay hang on here
again um
she she calls she calls that
transmuting energy blocks i call that
groping you sick weirdo
and the dog is looking back like dude
what the hell go transmute your own
energy
get your hands off of me this this is
this is taking a
very unexpected and disturbing turn
let's let's keep watching
[Music]
okay seriously again what what the hell
is happening here this woman should not
be allowed within 500 yards of a petting
zoo
is all i can say do you know what her
background is
nope she they just said they found her
on the street because i'm hearing her
say like she was used as bait
i don't know like that was something i
thought too because she's so small and
she's so skittish you know i'm so sorry
that that happened to you i really
really am and she said you know
sometimes other dogs make me nervous
oh yeah a lot i was blown away there
were some things that just
clarified a lot of elsa's behavior if
another dog barks at elsa first like
she's very
reactive in fear it's not like you know
an angry it's a oh my god why is that
dog
dog freaking out at me so that didn't
surprise me at all and almost was just
kind of like justification to something
i already just kind of
had a feeling was true let me just say
here uh one at one other point i
and this is not charitable but there's a
small part of me that
sort of wanted that pitbull to go
berserk and start eating people's faces
um god forgive me i did have that
thought i did
also what exactly was the pet owner
impressed by she said she was blown away
because the pet psychic explained
that dogs get skittish when other dogs
bark at them
but i'll tell you what you can come to
my house give me a thousand dollars
and i will blow your mind by telling you
that
fish to prefer to be in the water you
can bring your goldfish
i'll put my hand on the bowl yes yes i'm
getting something here i'm getting a
reading
yes yes he's telling me that he likes to
be in the water
wow how did you know nothing makes an
event more exciting than putting some
money on it and with my booking it's
easier than ever to get in on the action
sometimes you have a gut feeling about a
match-up sometimes you're just
betting on your team because they're
your team regardless whether you've been
betting for years or you're ready to
play for the first time my bookie is
your go-to this season with the biggest
online selection of bets and props
they made it simple to win and easy to
withdraw your cash head over to mybookie
to create an account
just used promo code walsh to claim your
100 deposit match all the way up to a
thousand dollars
that means if you put a hundred dollars
in they'll give you a hundred dollars
it's an easy way to jump start your
bankroll
nfl mba mlb everything else they've got
it all
on tap and it's never too late to get
started on your winning season
only at my bookie okay now i think we've
probably seen enough of that one let's
move on and check out one more this one
is very interesting because here we have
a pet psychic
communicating with a dead animal okay
communicating beyond the grave
it's hard enough to talk to a dog how do
you talk to a dog
who literally doesn't exist anymore that
takes a special kind of talent
or mental illness let's uh let's check
it out all right laura okay
what are we gonna do so we're gonna talk
to mikey who's in spirit
and um he recently passed away
right and um we're gonna see what he has
to say
uh what does he have to say he has
nothing to say because he's a dog
and he's dead but all right let's keep
going
i'm anxious to talk to her okay let me
get him
[Music]
here
he says you have to tell my mom and dad
that i'm forever with them
that he can run around and shake his
toys in heaven
[Music]
he says that he's run up and jumped on
the bed with you guys
he says he's also been nudging you a lot
so so what i'm taking from this
is that the dog is haunting the house
they have a ghost dog haunting them
and jumping on the bed at night this is
uh this is terrifying this is like the
this is a
plot to a horror movie what else has the
ghost dog been up to we'll find out now
have you felt him you know i i've been
trying to but i i
haven't been able to do that you've been
trying to yeah i've been trying i've
been looking for him i've been
kind of like feeling like where is he
okay again stop it there
uh what where is he he he's dead
that's where he is glad i could help
i haven't so the number one way that
they can let you know that they're
around you
is they can place a memory in your mind
that's all i have and then wrap their
spirit around you so then those memories
come with intense emotion like you want
to start to laugh or you want to start
to cry
they're usually a little bit more like
crystal clear the memories and they sort
of bring you to grief really fast
yeah so that's him touching you and so
when you feel that
see if you can kind of sit with it and
be like mikey is that you
you know and just sort of experiment
with sort of feeling what do you feel
inside and what you feel around you
because you might feel like a softness
or a sense of peace come over you or
or you might see the atmosphere look a
little different a little crisper or the
sounds might be a little crisper
all right let's stop it there again i
this is an interesting theory see i
thought that memory
was a neurological function involving
the hippocampus and the prefrontal
cortex of the brain that's what i
thought um
admittedly i'm not a scientist
apparently memories come from the
magical angel dogs who can control our
minds
that's fascinating i wonder if we can
appease these spirits by building an
altar and burning dog biscuits at
sacrifice
maybe she'll get to that next let's
watch he says you know how
about coming back he says i don't want
to tell you because i want them to just
feel it so i think what he's saying
is like that when you're ready to get
another dog you're gonna feel it
together
and you're gonna go look together and
that's when you'll find him
he says what he wants to tell you that's
really special is that there's
home on the other side
he says you're even here like what do
you mean mikey like mom and dad are
in heaven with you everything that i
loved about them is here with me
like what he says sometimes you know how
dad would get silly with me and play
sometimes we do that
and how mom would give me those kisses i
feel that all the time
there's something about like the way you
rub his face
too he feels okay i think we get the
idea here
um we get the idea what a few a few
final points
first of all now i'm worried that our
dead pets
really do hang around in spirit that
means that when my wife's cat finally
does
die i'll still have to deal with with
the cat in ghost form
cat ownership is apparently an eternal
curse
which is something that i tried to
explain to my wife before she brought
the damn thing home
that was actually those were my exact
words when she said we should get a cat
i said it is an eternal curse
and i was right second thing i almost
feel bad making fun of this because
on one hand it seems clear that these
people are not well
psychologically on the other hand it's
hilarious
so what am i supposed to do also as i
watch this i start to wonder if this is
some sort of like professional wrestling
type of thing
do all the people involved understand
that it's fake but enjoy it anyway by
some kind of
as some kind of strange sort of theater
performance
or is that too optimistic i don't know
it probably is the reality unfortunately
is that the world is full of crazy
people
and many of them own pets and this is
the result
so we might as well laugh at it